[Music]
welcome back to the Morty Jebsen show
i'm oniy Jepson we're here today
continuing that conversation with
unbelievable mega superstar young
bidness
now young bidness I gotta tell you we've
been tiptoeing around a particular
subject all day and I think it's time to
broach it you've separated recently with
you the actress girlfriend tina bouquet
no and everyone wants to know more yeah
we ain't gonna talk about that I'm not
here to talk about this I just went to
the store and lots of people understand
that you're talking about you know more
experience it's more the fans ain't good
like to know honey you and Jane want to
know how about that young view so
completion done there's no need for the
interview to be over it'll do so young
[ __ ] yeah all y'all [ __ ] young
Venice there's no need for the language
or any of this we can just you know
that's what I'm gonna talk about that
you want to talk about the album cuz I'd
be more than happy to talk about the
album this is the C word more it looks
like it's well on its way to going
platinum or CD s go well on its way to
going platinum we can talk about this as
kind of a job well would you say in by
the fireman thing let's talk about the
awkward song with um how about their
tanks of truth take the truth Zenit a
treatise on the conflict of Isis I mean
what it would talk to me about this what
your business please I'm begging you
take a deep breath oh let's discuss
let's discuss the out it's done Mort
it's done
brought this on yourself for business I
would really want it on yourself Fitness
young bidness I would really love it if
you had a seat and we could just talk
together about anything anything you
want we don't I won't mention Tina's
name again
youthful Commerce get the [ __ ] off me
Lewis Lewis go
leave it be exacerbating the situation
cord is blending in with the color of
the carpet
okay I just think that why don't you
drop the mic cables there and have a
seat this is what we used to call back
in the Army a fubar okay let me just
tell you don't get don't don't get
involved you see to get you out of here
they need me please can we just get
listen here no don't you let go of it
don't get in it don't see Ryan to get
around $1,500 agate [ __ ] get you know
why do we have black cords and a black
carpet I told y'all I wasn't gonna those
Lewis I swear to [ __ ] god we're gonna
take care of it
just stay put get now you got don't wait
tonight may I help you don't I'm sorry
okay you know what okay have a seat here
put your family do it what do you do
this everything don't you ain't taking
the pants off in a cult god damn it
where is Jerry this is some [ __ ] right
here same sound guy for 2017 vanishes no
colles got God's sake all right Lois
Lois hold back don't do anything but
hold that okay you gotta take no you
can't take the pants off over the shoes
you can't take your pants off over the
shoes Lois Lois get your white ass out
the [ __ ] you ain't helping nobody
all right I reckon the shoes off okay
alright that's one person
all right well [ __ ] do whatever you
[ __ ] want then they look fine thank
you one two thank you I told y'all I'm
gonna talk about that [ __ ]
we'll be right back with Alec Baldwin
you